[Música]
mónica cuesta bailarina y coreógrafa
graduada de la universidad de south
florida tiene más de 10 años de
experiencia en la gestión cultural tanto
en la empresa pública como privada
diseñadora de la carrera de danza de la
universidad católica santiago de
guayaquil maestra de danza kinesiología
e historia del arte en varias
universidades actualmente es la
presidenta de la sección guayaquileña
del consejo internacional de danza de la
unesco
en 2010
hace dos años atrás la última vez que
estuve parada sobre estas tablas fue
bailando por lo general lo verbal no es
muy fuerte así es que vamos a ver cómo
nos va y día
esa soy yo bajo los ojos y habilidades
de mi hija de nuestra hija por este
mismo sito
y le pedí a ella que haga un dibujo de
mí y justamente en este proceso de
decidir de que iba a hablar hoy día y
cómo lo iba a exponer
y siempre me veo reflejada en los
trabajos que ellas hacen y en sus
palabras entonces le pedí ese favor y
así empezó entonces así me ve ella tiene
6 años
y me acordé en este proceso de una
introducción que yo les hago a mis
alumnos
soy maestra de una clase que se llama
taller transdisciplinar y les hago una
introducción parecida a ésta en la que
demuestro las diferentes realidades que
tenemos como seres humanos yo soy mujer
soy mamá esposa administradora del hogar
que es la que menos me gusta
y artista gestora cultural amante de los
animales fanática the house of cards es
decir muchas muchas realidades que todos
tenemos
y he señalado lo artista como para
darles un ejemplo a mis alumnos en el
que si por algún motivo como artistas
tenemos un bloqueo creativo
no podemos ignorar nuestras otras
realidades para poder resolver el
problema y esto se debe a que el ser
humano es una identidad
discúlpeme algo estoy aplastando con
vida es una identidad indisoluble no nos
podemos separar
y entonces comencé a buscar en estos
cajones de mi historia porque si buscar
en los físicos nunca se encontraría nada
porque es un desastre buscan estos cajón
en la historia y dijo porque la danza
empezó en mí y llegué a la conclusión en
que la danza está en mí en mi sangre así
fui codificada y está en mí antes de que
yo tenga conciencia de eso
esta historia la contado en algunas
ocasiones y creo que hasta yo me aburro
de escucharme pero lo van a poder
entender mejor a los 3 años yo le he
pedido a mis padres que por favor me
registren en clases de ballet
primera clase fantástico seguramente
tiene que haber sido algo muy lúdico de
juego
y salí feliz segunda sesión ponen música
lo peor que me puede pasado me puse a
llorar y mi mamá me escucha desde afuera
de qué es lo que pasa la profesora
aterrada no sé está perfecta y de
repente se puso a llorar y mi respuesta
a los tres años fue que la música me dio
pena y así soy yo yo siento mucho
quisiera a veces no sentir tanto creo
que mi vida fuera mucho más sencilla
pero le doy muchos años después doy
gracias de por qué soy así
bueno mi formación académica de
bailarina avanzó mucho tiempo a los 16
años en plena del burro me peleo con la
danza como con enamorado y digo no
quiero saber más de esto y no sé si les
ha pasado que a veces cuando ustedes han
peleado o han terminado una relación con
alguien que de alguna u otra manera
siempre hay algo que les hace acuerdo a
esta persona bueno a mí me pasó así con
la danza decidí hacer deporte y a la
semana el profesor de solucionado me
dice pero niña no baile
entonces de nuevo es en recorderis
pasó el tiempo fui a la universidad a
estudiar algo totalmente distinto
por para tomar una clase electiva tomé
una historia de la danza porque si se me
ha gustado toda la vida si se me va a
ser fácil perfecto doy un paso en el
facultad
y amor a primera vista dije esto es lo
que quiero hacer para el resto de mi
vida
y así fue terminé estudiando dos
carreras simultáneas
pero en el último semestre así como las
relaciones amorosas se me rompió el
corazón porque tuve una lesión que me
impidió continuar con la misma dinámica
anterior
estando fuera del ámbito de la danza es
que pude reconocer todos los beneficios
de los que yo había gozado en todo este
proceso de formación
gracias a la danza tuve acceso a un
aprendizaje orgánico de la disciplina
del trabajar en equipo del ser líder del
ser liderada permitirme equivocarme
permitirme auto corregirme y todo esto
gracias a la danza entonces estando
afuera en otra perspectiva digo pero
porque en nuestro sistema educativo no
nos puede dar esas en esas bondades
y voy a citar al doctor
es el resumen de mi historia
el doctor pacis albert quien dice que
las instituciones educativas deben ser
lugares donde los estudiantes puedan
saber quiénes son y se descubran para
que son buenos no se trata tanto de
cuántos enseñas o cuánto se aprende y
eso me dio la danza a mí
como resumen la danza es beneficiosa
para la educación o cualquier expresión
artística
luego de esta ruptura de corazón por
decirlo así y que me ha dado otras
ventajas me he dedicado a la gestión
cultural entonces sí la danza siempre
estaba presente de alguna u otra manera
pero desde otro punto de vista decidió
coreógrafa productora a veces no solo de
danza sino también de eventos culturales
en general de teatro música etcétera
pero también por un antecedente y una
visión de lo que es la administración y
la economía he sido testigo de durante
estos 12 años que la danza es un agente
económico en la sociedad
en el 2010 las naciones unidas- da un
informe acerca de la economía creativa y
entre las casi 500 páginas del informe
resumen en que en los países ya
desarrollados
la economía creativa desde el 2000 hasta
el 2010 ha crecido más rápidamente que
y las industrias tradicionales o de
manufactura o de servicio y sugieren
para los países en desarrollo que se
forme un esquema más formal valga la
redundancia parecido al sistema que
mencionas o sentido en hebreo y lo voy a
citar porque es una persona fantástica
la música debe ser reconocida como un
agente social de desarrollo porque se
transmite los más altos valores
solidaridad armonía y compasión
en resumen
la danza es positiva para la educación
para la infancia la juventud la danza es
parte de la economía de una sociedad
fortalece y da cabida a lugares de
trabajo es buena para el adulto
productivo y es buena como un vínculo
entre la sociedad
y respondiendo a preguntas que yo misma
me sigue que otras personas me hacían y
siempre porque realmente te dedicas a la
danza y mi respuesta fue así y de lo más
improvisada pero es que si yo bailo está
en la ducha pero obviamente era mucho
más que eso
la danza es mi voz es allí donde me
permito ser vulnerable y eso me hace
fuerte
por eso es que decidí y se me dio la
oportunidad realmente muy agradecida y
honrada de ser una embajadora de la
danza a través del consejo internacional
adscrito de la unesco
porque la danza es un lenguaje universal
es mediador es conciliador
y sin duda somos un mundo mejor cuando
el arte o la danza nos conecta el uno
con el otro
ahí está mi bandera de la danza
para concluir quisiera hacer énfasis en
que si la danza es un elemento
qué es bueno para la educación para lo
económico y para lo social con un plan
de acción efectivo eficiente y sano
creo que la danza puede ayudar a nuestra
nación y a nuestra región a disminuir en
parte en la pobreza a la pobreza pero no
solo la pobreza material sino la humana
y la espiritual gracias
[Aplausos]